you know I'm not nice when I'm hangry
you know not nice but to be aware of it
like I'll actually say to somebody like
just so you know I'm a little hangry
probably not going to be a little bit
nice don't take it personally please I'm
fully aware of it this is something that
it took so long for my wife and I to
learn we will check in a few times a day
and just tell each other this is how I
feel this is what's currently happening
inside of me if one of us just wakes up
feeling
angry or tough or just like exhausted
you know for for whatever reason
we let each other know so that way
the person who's feeling it knows and
the other person who's around them is
aware of it so both people get more
information that wasn't there before and
it's been really helpful